bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
you are watching the Dean show when we
come back the importance of seeking
money it's nothing wrong with money we
like money but we got to get our
priorities straight phd's doctors
degrees master's degrees we should be
educated people but is it at the expense
of forsaking the most important
treasures the gems of wisdom the
knowledge of why we've been created why
are we why have we been put on this
earth where we go when we die these are
the most important questions the
knowledge that will bring us closer to
the one who created us the importance of
seeking true authentic knowledge of the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind the problem Hama peace be upon
him his sunnah and this is what we will
be discussing when we come back here on
edede show don't go nowhere this is the
theme
this is the main this is the things is
the teacher this is the thesis Athene
jus this is the danger
Salaam alaikum peace be with you sheikh
muhammad sal d how are you how are you
sir how's it going all right I'm excited
you're back in the studio how you been
you thank you hamdulillah getting old
and tried to manage what are you what
are you about in your late 30s early 40s
now about 60 + 60 Plus yeah so you've
been accumulating a lot of good deeds
they and Sean Logan praise at the leg
zipped up a good beat I mean I mean I
mean so shake tell us now we have a
short amount of time and the attention
span is even shorter for a lot of people
so we try to bring the excitement to the
table in a in a halal way but we want to
get serious two people are seeking
knowledge and as I said earlier is
nothing wrong with seeking knowledge
that will make you the best scientist
the best doctor but should we forsake
seeking the knowledge of the crater the
heavens the earth and our purpose in
life and all the wonderful things that
he wants us to do talk to us about the
importance of seeking that kind of
knowledge Charlotte miss Miller
hamdulillah otra semana rasool allah as
intelligence human being and Muslims we
have to set our priorities this is
something is very important and priority
is to get to know why you are here and
what is the most important the source of
this knowledge from where you want to
get this knowledge if we mess this point
so this is a serious problem so there is
nothing wrong for you to be professional
to be engineering to be BHD all these
things is good because you need to
benefit yourself benefit your society
benefit mankind in general but at the
same time it is very important as a
intelligence human being as Muslims that
we set a priority in our life there is
nothing wrong for you to be a
professional to be PhD degree whatever
degree but not to ignore or in the
expenses of
neglecting the knowledge which he
connected you to your Creator and to
make to to know about your purpose in
this life and we see the example that
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
he's a prophet he is the one who
receives the revelation but still in the
meantime Allah subhana tonic teaching
him and calling on him to say Walker Rob
be Sydney and say all my lord increase
me a knowledge so what can be more than
the prophet salallahu elam and he's
still making supplication do I asking
Allah to increase him in knowledge and
this shows you how important knowledge
in El Islam in actuality this is the
foundation you could not erect a
building without a foundation foundation
this is the foundation you have to have
the knowledge first so Islam make it the
fairest obligation is to learn and to
study to know about Allah Almighty is
this any kind of coincidence that the
first verses that will reveal where
accra of course because if you are not
going to read if you know what study if
your noble Taylor you could not guess in
the Islam doesn't build on guessing an
assumption it has to be reading
listening educating yourself accra read
but you see a las a panel thailand
saying fallom and now hula la la la what
stuff relieved mb memory bhai de la la
is saying chapter of seeking knowledge
before seen or action so before you do
anything you have to have the knowledge
about it otherwise you are not going to
do it right and the f you are not doing
it right is not going to be accepted
from you so Islam view knowledge to be
the phone dish action comes later now
many people they'll sit through classes
in the college and you know it's not
easy all the time you gotta listen to
the professor maybe he has you know a
boring moniteau way of presenting the
class like myself no you bring you you
have a very exciting way of doing it but
let's say someone's in class and they
want to get that that bachelors
associate's degree and they'll sit there
you know discipline themselves stead fat
because they see the end outcome exact
but now is there something different
with seeking the islamic knowledge the
knowledge of you know your purpose of
lies and the starting the written word
of God is it supposed to be exciting new
spot or you got to discipline yourself
to this also exactly understand body
sees a problem that we don't if you
don't believe in the unseen you will
have a big problem because you know
after it gets this bachelor we master
degree PhD degree whatever degree now
you're going to have an office you're
going to have a house you're going to be
making you can see that you can see that
touch it yeah but basically slam talks
about and latina u- Nabil right those
who believe in the unseen there is no
Jean I'm going to be given to you after
the club but you're going to work
towards Jean and it comes after this
thing's a higher paradise so exactly so
if you don't have this kind of
motivation you want to get tired it is a
type which you had yeah it is a type of
jihad is troubling you have to struggle
and we see that the prophets of allah
salaam all the Sahaba they did not get
it easy yeah it is it can you because we
you have a beautiful example you see
that how that office maybe on the 10th
floor you know you can see the house
that you're going to come to can we
fantasize because people fantasize what
they see on TV can we fantasize about
Jenna because we have all the proof that
is the truth and it's true understand is
nothing wrong and Islam build Oh enter a
panther heat okay do you give you this
can encouragement and to give you even
if on a lot of description concerning
Jannah paradise heaven in Quran and
hadith and enough enough you as a seeker
of knowledge the prophets allah allah
allah machine was the meaning is were in
that melon akola Tata as in Haiti had a
terrible l riddim be my asthma in these
the Angels lower their wings to the
seeker of knowledge because he bleeds
with what he's doing we are not talking
about the red carpet or body guards and
security and a special aeroplane and
reception no the angels will lower their
wings for you as a student of knowledge
so this is something you could not
that's a great honor isn't of course wow
wow this amazing let's take a break and
we right back with more
the D show Islam is the fastest growing
religion in the world and most of the
converts are women not men they see that
the rules of Islam instead of
constraining it the rule set them free
this is the theme jus ok put your dream
home and you've got your dream car but
you're gonna get old and things are
going to happen to you in your life and
then what have you got at the end of the
day is an empty dream that has no real
foundation we are gonna die and we're
gonna meet our Lord and he is going to
judge us it becomes an obligation for
each single human being to find out what
the Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person embed for the society it's
killing of innocent human beings human
life is precious back here Nadine show
we're talking about the importance of
seeking knowledge and like you said
there's no problem here with seeking
other knowledge no of the of the
material world so you can be the best
car mechanic or engineer that's not a
problem yes you have to do it everybody
have to do but the doctor have to learn
about to slam the mechanic have to learn
about Islam the teacher I have to learn
about Islam because this is our priority
and this is said your mannerism your
behavior your discipline is a guard its
protection for you how you going to
manage other things if it's money if his
family if it's professional so you need
the guidance the guidance of Monte Allah
and they threw accra bessemer of ecology
Halak read what kind of reading is the
name of your Lord the one who had
created things which connected to it is
a creator because he created you and he
created everything else so he giving you
the guidance how you conduct your time
your money your family he needed and as
a result of this the prophet salallahu
sell em say nor the meaning is my unit
11 be higher on your fork lake ohrid
Dean whosoever Allah Almighty it tends
goodness for him he will give him the
understand
in the religion not the understanding in
the F in the chemistry in the mountains
where is the religion because this will
give you the friendly relationship and
the proper direction how to utilize
everything and how to deal with
everything so you need this knowledge
first is it true that when the Muslims
they were implementing and learning the
the knowledge of their Creator from the
verbatim word of God the Quran and the
Sunnah they were the leaders in science
math and all these other world leaders
scientists you know this is true it is a
history you finally understand the dark
ages of America you understand the
Muslims had advanced in Spain in
different places in chemistry in science
in medicine in everything but when the
Muslim is started back up from learning
and get busy with the worldly thing and
was all this material and give it a
priority over the knowledge of Islam now
the lost both of them you don't have
this isn't there yeah hey bad is it true
that the last and final master sent
America and peace be upon us said that
the one who seeks knowledge allow make
the path to Jenna to paradise easy for
him man Salla Qatar Yukon Delta me
Sophie elma Saahil Allah Vittorio
cannella Jenna whenever he take a path
to knowledge Allah will make this egos
for you to get closer more to Jenna
because how are you going to know the
way to general is not experiments is not
a dream it's not a guessing is
revelation and this is the nourishment
of the soul all these other things is
only for the dollar ok like somebody
would say dollar Akbar yeah okay but we
need you understand the soul because the
soul has a control over everything your
mind your body every so you need like I
said the foundation phase the after
disick and erect your building tell us
give us some examples of one who just
chases the dollar as opposed to one
who's chasing and seeking the knowledge
that knowledge that will bring him
closer towards the Creator it's very
very simple example whenever you
understand you have some cash you be
walking and make sure that nobody
understand i'm going to get you snatch
it from you so you try to protect this
money but when you have the knowledge
you walk in feel secure because you're
walk-in in guidance and you are not
worried about that somebody want to
attack you you don't need a brings money
truck that we don't need it so actually
knowledge protection for you but you are
have to provide protection for the money
yeah you see when you have knowledge
people seek in you because the knowledge
but when you have the money people are
not they don't care about you see what
your dollar you see so is a big
difference for a person have a knowledge
and person have the money looked as a
knowledge you understand when you die
this is not the end of it it will help
you in your grave it helped you in the
day of judgment so knowledgeable goes
with you even to your grave you see does
the money go of course not the moments
that you died and is everything the
Cadillac or the limousine or whatever it
is everything stays there and you go
understand with nothing so people have
to understand where to invest their time
this is something very important and
where is the priority in their life and
this life is temporary and money also is
temporary is when you have it you happy
but you don't have it you are not happy
okay because it's not in your hand but
knowledge it will make you happy at any
time rich or poor why because knowledge
protect you give you the satisfaction it
feels you that you are not only about
material thing about something else
spiritually does it help you also in the
worldly matters like we know it's a
nourishment for the Soul but knowledge
of the beta mode of God the Quran and
all the other sciences of Islam does
this can this also help you in the
worldly matters of course because when
you seek knowledge this is a form of a
better a form of worshipping Almighty
God so that mean you are trying to
please God and this is the main thing
please your master now your master he
owned everything so if you trying to
come to please him now we can make
things more easier in you so if a person
wise enough
he will approach and take this shortcut
okay which will need you straight for
ease the dunya and the hereafter feel
and this world seeking knowledge and
learning the Dean the book of allah and
the authentic son of rasulullah
sallallahu give us some tips now okay
for the average Muslim the average
person let's say he's got so much
studying too he got books and books to
read so he can you know become that
doctors that he can get the PhD he's got
so many books so many classes how could
that person now if we can give a formula
for that person how they should study
how they should and how much they should
implement I'm sure it's going to be
easier for the person who doesn't have
that many books and he doesn't have that
much responsibility we are not asking
every Muslim to be a scholar but we
asking every Muslim to be at least
learning enough to perform his
obligation to Almighty Allah you need to
master about your ablution about your
purification about your prayer about
your fasting so there is certain things
that he may do not need it immediately
as example let's say that I'm a poor
person I don't need to learn about the
canal because I don't need I don't have
the money to give this a can all right
I'm not about to get married now ok so
is no need for me immediately now that I
learned about rules and regulation of
marriage duties and rights but every
Muslim from even 57 years old you need
to start to practice your prayer when
she reaches the age of puberty now you
are obligated to make prayer so
everybody have to learn how to master
the prayer so we say to the average
Muslim at least the five basics of the
deal you have to try to master them and
especially the things that necessary
immediately I don't have money to go to
make hajj so okay we can give you a
break you don't have to learn about Hajj
now what about you go learn about Salah
what about go learn about fasting
because he needs this immediately so he
still can be seeking both information
for the worldly thing and for the
Hereafter
you can give time and priority knowing
about your Creator and what he
requesting you to do and then the
meantime is still can studying to be a
professional to be adapter to be
engineer whatever you want some
practical things that I see that work
for many people so that I've talked to
now in the car when their car does this
helps a grab a lecture throw out that
music that's of no benefit don't lecture
exactly but something in there that
emulates your mind but but the CD bought
something like this so you can hear it
because this is one Allah Allah Allah
Allah let me some how absurd yeah so a
lots of Hannah Tyler made this fatality
or this facility for use hearing and
seeing okay the cottage gurus that you
be grateful so while it driving some
people drive every day at least 45
minutes to put their job you got right
there's knowledge you can benefit you
can put a lecture and listen to it
listen to it while you going listen to
at one time when you come it is already
there you are ma you're already you know
now you can anything exactly how about
at home now it's turn off all the
reality shows and you know the garbage
DiSanto no chose this is this is a big
damage for the muslim not wasting time
so in their time you can you can watch
good islamic something like this as
example watch the don't show the Dean
show put the TV peace TV anything that
now put thrown over gladly lined up
there you go let's take a break and
we're gonna be right back with more here
on the Dean shop
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say some positive awesome just hold
on to the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe rely I need a last minute
the court answers don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us it will
fail you mock you know Allah so that the
Prophet SAW shall have never ever start
a war against any of us and if we're
going to worship something I figured I
might as well worship with the Creator
instead of any of the creations now in
upon investigating the villages I
remember finding out the meaning of what
Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender yourself to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will Daisy Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God your Creator if
Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Eliza i am not
afraid to stand
show we're talking about the importance
of seeking knowledge okay we gave the
example the person now he's overloaded
with you know trying to get that PhD
he's got a lot of books to read we gave
some examples of you know on his time
out free time he can make that valuable
time putting in the CD in the car
watching if he takes a break the TV
instead of TV put electron and what
about the person now who has free time
and he finds himself spending let's say
or she finds herself spending a lot of
time gossiping or maybe playing the xbox
you know a person will spend hours a
week should this be cut out and fill
that time in with the seeking of
knowledge you know the so-called free
time that we have should we turn it into
valuable time knowledge time this is the
problem when we did not understand what
we hear in this life this life is a
field for you to plan it ok for the
Hereafter so you actually in in every
minute it's count for you or against you
this what you have to be worried about
it because you are nothing except a time
if God Almighty had decreed for you to
live 60 years ok so every second go away
you are an Elissa of your age one second
every day goes now you shorter and you
close up to your grave one day so we
have to start to wake up observe the
reality of this life and we have to try
to blend more seeds so we can gain more
fruit in the hereafter otherwise movies
it so time is your capital and you have
to see how you're going to invest in
this cavity this is something very
important is the person the worshiper
just a person that praise is he
equivalent to the person that praised
and seeks knowledge and then takes that
knowledge and not only benefits himself
in his favor benefits the community also
of course not you understand that a
person who only doing something to
benefit his own self okay but the other
person he extended it to others you see
so now we're sharing with others as a
result of this the professor la la salle
insane Jairo comenta a llamar Quran
while Emma the best among you those who
learned is the Quran and teach it to
others so you have to benefit your
itself and
benefit others and this is the best
approach if you want to be among the
best everybody want to be this and that
and okay because you know this is the
best what is best learning the Quran
teach it to others benefit yourself and
they tried to benefit others what's
benefited myself and others what I've
seen is not not only are you by seeking
this knowledge you're increasing this
helps you to increase in your email and
your faith and bus and is there any
knowing that there's no wasted time you
reading a book that is talking about
your crater and all the wonderful things
he wants you to do your responsibilities
and the other sciences there's no waste
of time for every minute you spend
seeking this knowledge are you getting
rewarded for of course it's been little
informal this is a form of a better it's
not only when you pray you worshiping
Allah seeking Allah and learning the
proper way to a broader Almighty Allah
this is a form of a bed itself you are
not wasting it that's a form of worship
of course of course yes amazing amazing
amazing we're at a time thank you again
for being with us o people can see more
of your shows at the Dean show com you
have your own section there and we look
forward to inshallah being back with you
gotta thank you very much thank you
hello for you and some great advice
seeking knowledge is incumbent on every
Muslim male or female and I'm going to
tell you a little secret is not a secret
but maybe if you forgot if you want to
be rich with the creator of the heavens
and earth gain this knowledge and then
share it share with others share this
knowledge this basic knowledge on what's
the purpose of life you can share this
is very simple share the knowledge of
who the crater is that he's one and
alone worthy of worship all these basic
things that the human beings they're
empty in the soul many of them they're
confused in darkness and when having the
true knowledge you're in the light like
a person in a dark room you turned on
the light now you can see share this
light with humanity we have the dvds for
Dawa that you can pick up make copies of
them give them to the non-muslims the
people now that are your neighbors your
colleagues and make sure to visit us
here every week on the Dean show until
next time peace be unto you